[Music]
it's not even december 25th yet that's
about 16 days and counting but santa
claus
as is his way is already making
christmas wishes come true
seven-year-old annalise hawking of new
hampshire wrote to the big man in the
red suit asking him
for just one thing for christmas all she
wanted was to find her friend nyla
the two girls how cute are they became
best friends in school there they are
last year
but when nila's family moved and the
family went into quarantine they lost
contact
nikki batista is in new york city's
hudson yard neighborhood with this
charming is the word for this nikki what
did annalise say in her letter to santa
they're both adorable these two
so adorable good morning gail and while
of course most kids
ask for toys for christmas sweet
annalise hawking
simply wanted to find her best friend's
new address so she could write her
and when santa and his elves read her
letter they decided to make some
christmas
magic santa
for christmas i would like it to be a
surprise
please tell myla that i miss her
this priceless christmas wish from
seven-year-old annalise hawking
stood out when it arrived at the north
pole last week
please tell her my address
she simply wanted help finding her
eight-year-old friend
nyla loftis a lot of kids asked for toys
why did you want to ask to see your
friend this year
i asked to see myla because
i really missed her the two girls became
best friends last year after nyla helped
annalise
whose family was new in town feel
welcome
but when nyla's family moved away in
february the second graders
lost touch so annelise turned to the one
person who makes
miracles happen santa claus with a
little help from
annelise's mom leslie posted a photo of
the letter to facebook
asking if the community could help find
nyla
over 100 people responded i was
definitely crying a little bit
santa posted it on facebook and all
these people
had helped him we found her like i can't
believe this happened
it actually chokes me up right now i was
just
amazed that a little girl would ask that
moms leslie and sarah knew they had to
get their daughters together
so they planned a surprise meet up
neither poked your head up
you were surprised we hugged and
i couldn't talk speech because i didn't
know what to say
if you could say something to santa
right now i think he's listening
what would you like to say thank you for
making my wish come true
leslie and sarah are grateful for all of
santa's helpers who made their
daughter's reunion possible
people in this time of year feel an
extra sense of giving
and i think this brought out the best in
people in a lot of ways
sarah how has this all impacted nyla and
your family because she is also in a new
school now it's been great seeing her
smile because it's been so hard
this has definitely made her so more
cheerful
she still has her best friend in a
difficult year
two best friends reminding us of the
simple joys
this holiday
anna-lysa nila now face time regularly
and their families hope to get them
together
again when the pandemic slows down both
girls have been remote learning so
seeing each other was extra special
anthony
yeah what that power of connection nikki
thank you
power of connection and the power of
friendship yeah just the fact that these
two bonded the way they did at such an
early age yeah and you can see it in
that photograph which i just love i
couldn't watch enough